do you find it challenging to maintain
identities across different environments
in hybrid and multi cloud deployments do
you wish you can leverage your existing
identity investments for anthos well
keep watching as we cover how you can
use Antos to simplify identity
management for users and workloads hi
I'm Priyanka Vergara and welcome to
anthos 101 with Ando's our goal is to
make it seamless for you to modernize
and manage your workloads in an
environment that you prefer whether it
is on from google cloud edge or a
different cloud and those spans across
multiple environments and each is built
on different identity store for example
Active Directory for on Prem cloud
identity for Google Cloud and AWS I am
for AWS in addition to employee identity
you may need to manage partner winter
identity workload identity or customer
identity further increasing the
complexity traditionally gugus vowed has
offered a synchronization based identity
model requiring you to synchronize
identities with Google cloud while this
may work for certain scenarios you may
have concerns around consistency and
latency for a hybrid or multi cloud
deployment with anthos we want to meet
you where you are and those identity
service extends existing capabilities
and enables you to use third-party
identity providers and authentication
protocols following a federation model
this service can be deployed quickly in
your anthos gk cluster enabling
protocols such as open ID connect you no
longer need to synchronize identities to
Google cloud or worry about consistency
across environments it saves time and
reduces friction during the onboarding
process and those on Prem offers a wide
easy support which enables
authentication we our G cloud or through
cloud console let's walk through how
that experience looks like say you are a
platform administrator managing a small
team of developers and you're interested
in providing access to the kubernetes
api server
to debug issues or perform cluster
management tasks using cube CTL after
creating a user cluster for gke on Prem
you can run a gke CTL command to
generate a login configuration file you
will need to populate this file with
values specific to your identity
provider such as issuer URL redirect URL
and client ID you can enable one or
multiple identity providers to support
needs of different user groups the file
can be securely distributed to
developers using an accessible URL in
order to restrict access based on
privileges granted to authenticated
users you can use kubernetes role-based
access control to create cluster rules
that grant specific privileges to users
and groups as a developer you can
install the G Cloud SDK without
requiring a Google Cloud identity
account and install the Antos art
components to enable third-party Oh IDC
authentication simply run g-cloud Antos
login to view the list of available
clusters and specify a cluster flag to
login
based on your kubernetes rback
privileges you can now run cube CTL
commands to complete your required tasks
moving forward we're planning to enable
additional protocols such as LDAP to
support authentication needs for
multiple environments including Google
Cloud on-prem and other clouds
we're also extending our oid c
capabilities to other clouds to create a
consistent multi-cloud experience and
those identity service is designed to
work seamlessly with other anthos
components and your existing identity
investments beyond user authentication
you can also enable workload
authentication for workloads running in
gke to consume services provided by
Google api's simply configure a
kubernetes service account to
automatically authenticate when
accessing Google Cloud NPI's there's no
need to worry about safeguarding private
keys for PKI and client certificates or
managing bearer and bootstrap tokens and
those identity service provides a fully
integrated enterprise
ready solution for authentication that
is built with security in mind as you
can see and those identity service
offers a seamless solution for managing
authentication to multiple anthos gk
environments allowing you to leverage
existing identity investments and
streamline the onboarding process to
learn more about anthos identity service
and our identity features check out the
documentation below and for more anthos
content don't forget to subscribe and
follow the anthos 101 playlist
[Music]